peter zahan is one of the most well
respected geopolitical analysts in the
world he recently had a conversation
with some of the folks over at arc
invest and they were talking about
monetary policy fixed rules and whether
global nations around the world could
actually go ahead and trust something
like the us dollar or bitcoin it's a
fascinating conversation but hear first
exactly what they were saying
why is that fixed supply important to
you
it wouldn't have to be a fix of instead
instead just a predictable and unchanged
as in you know what the rules of the
game are
how would this
influence the geopolitical environment
if every country could trust that this
was kind of the reality well i think you
just described the dollar except no
because the the foreign government like
a problem with the dollar for emerging
markets is that you know the dollar
supply is uh controlled to the interest
of the us domestic economy often in a
way that negatively impacts other dollar
sensitive um or other dollar dependent
economies i totally hear you and that's
definitely one of the criticisms of the
dollar the problem is we have yet to
find anything better and i would argue
that that's never going to be something
like bitcoin
now of course peter's got a great point
here the u.s dollar was that monetary
policy that everyone could trust the u.s
said here's what we're going to do and
the us did exactly what they said they
were going to do and that served us well
for decades and decades that's why the
u.s dollar has been the global reserve
currency and so many different people
around the world continue to use it but
all of a sudden in recent times we've
seen the us go ahead and change their
mind multiple times on top of that you
kind of have to be the friend of the
united states in order for them not to
go ahead and freeze you out sanction you
or be nefarious or abrasive towards your
country now of course i don't actually
know where the world's going but what i
do know is that there is one asset
bitcoin that has a decentralized
programmatic monetary policy that means
that nobody in the world no individual
or organization can actually control it
or change it and on top of that because
it's programmatic everyone in the world
knows exactly what's going to happen
when it's going to happen and you can
audit it at any time from anywhere in
the world i don't know how valuable
that's going to be but something tells
me given the light of so much
undisciplined monetary policy in the
world both in the us dollar and other
fiat currencies there's a lot of people
who are going to start to say hey this
bitcoin thing that's pretty cool i like
something where i know the rules and i
also know that they're never gonna
change hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time